we have laryn's own sven winker without
his regaling armor but
here to talk about wonderful baldur's
gate 3. thank you so much for joining us
hi dave nice to be here we um we had a
short little
presentation um let's say it went uh as
well as d d can be expected
one thing that i think a lot of people
are curious about because you're going
the early access route for baldur's gate
three
how many hours of content are the
players going to
have to toy with when it releases in
early access i mean quite a lot already
uh i don't have an exact number but i
think you
you can i don't want to pinpoint the
number because otherwise i will be
quoted on it
but it's sufficient you'll be busy you
can compare it i think to divinity
originals
two's amount of content and probably
more and then that's going to be in
there
that and that's at early access or
that's what you're aiming for
no that's early access that the actual
complete game is going to be much bigger
than that so what state will the the
core
campaign be in when you hit that maybe
early access date so you'll have what we
call
the first act or large parts of the
first act maybe we'll have to cut some
things out
depending on where we are with our
development schedule
but you will be able to play through a
couple of uh
let's call them big quest lines that are
present in there there's a whole bunch
of subquests a whole bunch of
of uh tangent story beats that you'll be
able to explore
uh i mean like when i'm saying uh
being able to play through a couple of
core quest lines i'm talking about main
story
paths which take easily 15 to 20 hours
uh so you'll be able to explore
uh yeah all kinds of things you'll be
able to go to the underdark you'll be
able to
visit various overland places
you will be able to play as a warlock
you'll be able to play
as a wizard
fighter ranger um
i'm forgetting one and there's six
classes that you can play as in the
beginning
and you will have several subclasses for
those and there'll be different traces
that will be present also so
a good portion actually um
and you'll be able to play up to a
certain level cap but we're still
like uh trying to to get a handle of
exactly what is going to be in there
and we're reserving the right to cut
some things because as we explained
the development right now is not ideal
because not everybody is in the office
so working from home does slow down
things and after the
the first early access release
how are you aiming to grow the
experience um
with each update uh
by adding more stuff and improving it
and then reacting to
to what the community is telling us so
that's pretty much our been our early
access pass in the past also so we'll
we'll
release more things we'll release more
classes we'll release
probably extra origin stories maybe
separate
regions if we don't put everything in
there on the early access date for act
one
and then you'll see more and more
features come online more mechanics user
interface we'll be going through changes
uh so pretty much everything that you
would expect us to do
during early access what will be
happening for this game do you have a
content goal in relation to
like fifth edition i know some people
are hoping for the whole
players handbook of fifth edition to be
represented
um is is that like the end goal like
getting all of fifth ed in or do you
have like another
like this is when it's it's done sort of
thing uh
a good portion of that i mean like there
are things that we're not putting in
but there's a lot of things that we are
putting in and so and again
uh we are trying to
give ourselves a little bit maneuvering
room uh so by by not announcing exactly
everything that we want to put in there
uh just for the same reason uh we we
need to have the bandwidth or the
ability to to cut some things if it's
necessary
but there is that set there's a lot
that's going to be in
one of the changes that um you've made
since we we last spoke and i saw the
game
is there's been changes to the
initiative system um
could you talk us through the the new
version that you have so um
last time we showed it we had just
developed a side initiative system
where you had basically it was either
your party and then the enemy or
the enemy and then your poor party and
maybe another faction
uh so now it is more of a classic turn
order where
everybody rolls for initiative and that
basically sets up a sequence
in which each participant in combat will
get get its turn
however if there are multiple people
from your party
that are ending up in the same bucket if
you want
you can uh change the sequence in which
you're giving them orders so you could
for instance if you have uh
lysel and gail and will for instance
will the warlock
which you didn't see today
[Music]
and they all ended up next to one
another then you could for instance ask
will uh to go first do one move and then
you could jump to lyzelle have her do a
move then go back to will have him do a
move
uh until they're out of actions bonus
actions and so forth
and then it would be the next turn and
then like that it continues
one of one of the things that i think
with a lot of dos 2 players this might
be their first entry to boulder's gate
um the environmental and elemental
effects
are much more muted but more seemingly
more important
in baldur's gate 3. yeah so
when we started developing the game we
were looking for
ways that we could give players an
intuitive sense of how to get advantage
in combat
advantage is a very important concept as
is disadvantage in dungeon and dragon's
fifth edition
and so the very first one that came to
mind was verticality it's very easy to
understand that if you have the high
ground you're gonna have an advantage
over your enemy
so we started building a world which is
full of verticality so you'll see plenty
of overhangs and bridges going over
stuff and chasms and
you can jump on giant mushrooms and
shoot from there and so there's a lot of
ways of getting advantage
and then we added the ability to remove
the advantage from an enemy
and by for instance destroying the
things in which they're standing so they
could be standing on a bridge then you
can collapse the bridge or
the demo i gave you we were walking over
spider webs so i could shoot burn that
spider up and then you fell down
so we started those doing those things
and then we started looking for other
ways that we could do this
and so that's how our light and dark
system came to be so
indulgent dragons you have these rules
around obscurity like you could be
heavily obscured
lightly obscured so we started adding
that so if you walk in the shadows
you're lightly obscured but if you're in
a very dark environment you might be
heavily obscured
and then we added things like dark
vision and we might see through that
or not and so all those things started
mixing with each other
and then we had a an environment which
you can move everything around if it
looks like it can be moved around and if
you're strong enough
and then we are allowed things like if
you have a potion there's a liquid in
there and you throw it that liquid is
going to spread so you start getting
surface
gameplay and we put all of that together
in one big sandbox
and that allows you as a player when
you're in combat and you have to
overcome a challenge
to really use your creativity in trying
to figure out how
to be victorious which is like today
we've been through a couple of fights
and we had to be very creative
we failed actually but we had to be very
creative trying to achieve
uh achieve our objective and there was
many things that i could do
just by interacting with the environment
using gravity to my advantage using the
objects that were at my disposal to my
advantage throwing things
so and that makes for an experience
that's very close to what you get when
you're playing a tabletop session
so in terms of the story obviously when
you're playing tabletop the story that
you create and the characters is hugely
important
when it comes to your party and the
player that
you are playing as what story kind of
takes precedent do you
are you experiencing the more
simultaneously or is like the lead
character story the one that
is the focus well obviously there's the
lead character story
it's his story or her story like how it
starts
but then as you progress through the
game you start meeting companions their
stories start interweaving with your
story
and so progressing from there you get
a yeah you get a very subtle
level of storytelling i think where
everything weaves together
as the party journeys together and tries
to achieve their goal
and then depending on how the
relationships develop because there's
lots of permutations in this game
somebody might betray you somebody might
sacrifice themselves for you
you might sacrifice yourself or someone
else it really depends on where you're
going to drive it
and through all of that the key thing is
player agency so there's lots and lots
and lots of choices to be made
the other thing is also the that d20
role which we made central in the game
where
every single time you have to persuade
somebody or make an important decision
there's a dice that starts rolling and
you can manipulate it you're using a
mechanic called inspiration points
but what the way the dice rolls is going
to define
how your story progresses and that makes
for an enormous amount of replayability
also
so what options are there for if i'm not
playing as one of the characters
that that becomes one of the origin
characters and i want to create my own
character what options are there for
crafting
my own story uh so where the demo i gave
you today was actually a custom
character so that was a character that i
had created
and that's very similar to what you
would get in the player handbook from
dungeon dragon so you get to select your
class
your your race your sub racer class uh
your background you get to fool around
with your ability points
uh so you can pretty much select what
spells you're gonna have
what countries if those are available to
you if you're a cleric or domain what
gods
all those things are available to you
and then when you start playing you see
that the world is very reactive to who
you are what you picked what class you
are what race you are uh
what you have uh at what proficiencies
you have
so all these things come into play and
um
to be honest in a way that is much more
refined than what we did in for instance
originals and two with lots more
a lot more permutations a lot more
consequences also to uh the choices that
you make in there
and well when we've we've that some of
the stuff we've seen so far in the game
um some of the options that you have in
dialogue is using the tadpole
in your head that's going through the
serif ceremonies process
um and some of the dialogue hints at
things like you start losing
um what what downsides is the character
having to with when the tadpole is
basically eating its brain
yeah so there is a buff towards darkness
that you can take
and which means that you start using the
powers that the tadpole gives you
and where that leads you that's
something that i'll let you discover for
yourselves
as you as you play the game but um
it's very much similar to what we had in
the original games that if you take the
path of darkness
there are consequences and advantages to
be honest
it is one of those games where evil is
actually being rewarded uh as
a play style so it can go
very far but then of course there's also
consequences to all of those actions
which makes it a cool experience
and when it comes like you're saying
that things things change and the world
reacts and
the one of the core experiences when
you're building a character in dnd is
you're
thinking about its alignment but from
what i've seen there's no
official alignment chart in boulder's
gate three
is it more that just the world is
reacting to each and every decision and
there's
there's much more player agency than
just saying i'm chaotic evil
and i do chaotic evil things it seems
like it's shades of grey more than
anything
it is although we have added alignment
in character creation now
so uh that is coming so you you will be
able to
to use your alignment and alignment uh
is
having an impact on a whole bunch of
little systems that are present in there
but we don't want to force you down a
particular path just because you picked
one alignment so it is
in the narrative choices that you're
making you still have the entire range
that is at your
your disposition where the alignment and
the choices that you make start
mattering is
in your relationship to your companions
and in the relationship of the world
towards you if you do something
that is utterly evil and you have
somebody in your party that is for
instance lawful good
uh you can expect your approval rating
to drop dramatically
uh whereas if somebody in your party is
evil and you're doing something that is
evil
and that approval rating would actually
increase so you will see that
interaction happen
i'm assuming in similar games there's if
if the reaction
gets too low if you are being chaotic
evil
a paladin might go you know what see ya
i'm i'm gonna adventure with someone
else or are they
are your stories stuck together no might
also try to attempt to murder you at
night
these things are good you might wake up
with a dagger
on your throat if you if you really piss
them off
oh great i can't that's something for me
to look forward to
so in terms of of multiplayer we know
how like some of the npcs might react
how
is multiplayer going to work in bold
skate 3 both from a gameplay standpoint
and
a narrative standpoint so multiplayer
everybody is their own hero
so you each have your personal story but
you live through that story as a party
so the moments that we force you to come
together is when you go to camp camp is
one of our
central instruments in the storytelling
in bg3
so there's a lot of stuff happening
there i showed you today how you met the
devil rafael the gambian raphael
so he arrived in my camp i might have
actually encountered him in the world
also
i might have encountered him during a
recruitment moment of companion
or at different locations but if i would
have missed all of those eventually he
would probably show up in camp
because he's a central narrative beat
because he wants to offer you a pact and
it's going to be up to you
to decide whether or not if you're going
to go for that or maybe one of your
party members or one of your other human
players
will decide to say you know i'll take
the deal and then you'll say no i'm not
going to take that deal and then
suddenly we have an interesting
situation going on in our camp
so other than that in multiplayer it
pretty much
plays as if you are going to be playing
in single player we can split the party
we can
doing all kinds of crazy things all over
the world the others will have to live
with
consequences of those decisions if you
decide to kill
the leader of a bunch of refugee thief
links
because and i promise to help them well
i'll
i'll be there right you killed him i'll
have to deal with the fact that he's
dead now and the entire camp has an
approach
so these are all things that play
as natural as you would expect them to
to play out
and i think that we learned a lot from
original sim 2 where we did this for the
well actually we did it for the first
time in original sin one
refined and endos too and i think you'll
find the next evolutionary step of
storytelling and multiplayer and nbg3 so
is there any
are you ready to talk about the
potential of a dungeon
master mode similar to dos 2 is that
something you guys are thinking on
well certainly we are thinking about it
but it's not implemented i mean like um
we we had to make a very large team to
make vg3 and every single one of those
people is very very very
focused and committed and above all
extremely busy
on just making the core experience of
the campaign to work so right now
there's no development being done on any
dungeon mastermind
not to say that we won't ever do it i
mean this literally we just
right now have to make the game work and
it's a very big game
you can do a lot of stuff in this game
yes i have uh i've seen many at boots
thrown so far
um you talked a little about your camp
and in the session we had there was the
potentiality of
a gnome joining um what how how does
your camp grow
is it simply somewhere to sleep and
interact with your
party or will there be things like
merchants and
and crafting or like how big is this
camp going to get you can acquire quite
a lot of camp followers and these cam
followers will start interacting with
you and your companions
um i think why you probably didn't see
it but
i showed you a level three party their
camp had actually already grown based on
what we showed you originally
uh so you saw a little tents that
appeared there there was a little cave
with candles in there
things that weren't present in the at
the very beginning of the game where you
just had like a little campfire and that
was it
and so the way that that is going to
grow well you'll discover us
as you play the game obviously like i
said it's somewhere to rest
um and there's uh the difference between
a short rest and a long rest and
and if you're familiar with dnd you
might understand that but
for traditional rpg players can you
explain how the rest system works in
relation to
how your parts performs as well as when
it comes to
spells because bald skate doesn't have
like a traditional
mana system right so you get a spell
slot system uh which has actually been
quite a challenge to try to explain to
people what spells are
and so we've done a little ui work i
think we're going to be successful with
it but we'll see during early access
uh so and spells also are essentially a
resource that you use
uh and when you you use them up as you
cost
spells so you need to sleep to get to
regain them
and depending on what your class is that
can be an easier thing to do or a harder
thing to do
and so ultimately you need to rest
take a long rest to restore your entire
party so that it has all of its
resources again
and so but um because of the way that
the world works and also a little bit
how contentious and dragons works it's
all not always safe to rest
so there's zones that are unsafe and so
if you're an unsafe zone the only thing
that's at your disposition
is a short rest and so a short race
doesn't restore everything
and so we have a short rest system in
the long-range system and so when you
try to go to the camp
and the game says well this is a
dangerous zone it's going to say well do
you want a short rest
right and if you can go to camp then
i'll just let you go to camp and or you
could also have
just indicated that i just want a short
dress i don't need a long rest right now
so that's how it's done it's very
natural and then when you go to camp
if the party members have nothing really
to tell you you just fall asleep right
away but if they have something to say
to you
you arrive in camp you see that there's
just some people that want to talk to
you and so camp moments happen so it's
very
smooth let's put it that way this might
be something personal to me but whenever
i play d d
if i find an animal chances are i'm
going to try and charm it and tame it
is there going to be like pets or
animals that you can
add to your camp as well get a little
wolf follower that you managed to
yes yes there are animal camp followers
uh well you'd be surprised what type and
good i'd like to get the pet question in
there because
dm dms everywhere hate me because if i
see a bear i'm trying to roll the 20 to
charm it
okay that wasn't that wasn't
me like trying to get things out of you
or saying hey you should add a bear to
your game
i promise an early access uh
there's an opportunity to take a cup uh
and it's it's it's a kind of bear it's
not exactly a bear
oh god okay well now now you've got the
the gears turning all over again
so how how is your party going to change
through the campaign we saw
a lot of pie members unfortunately die
um
is there a thing like all party members
died
is there like such a thing as
perma-death you spoke a little bit about
um if your ideologies clash they can try
and kill you or leave
how much can a party change through a
campaign we basically discern
between companions so these are people
that have a full-fledged story
so if they join your party they will
have relationships you can talk to them
they have different
quests that they want you to do which
might be opposing to the quests with
other companions have
and then you also have uh what we call
uh call it uh mercenaries
so they don't really have a set story
but they have the advantage that you can
say well that's
exactly the type of character that i
wanna wanna build like this uh
so you basically select who is gonna be
in your party if you pick a companion
you get a richer narrative experience
if you want to have more of a mechanical
if you want experience you'll take a
mercenary they won't have that much to
say
but at least you will still be able to
continue even if you pissed off all of
your companions
because i didn't agree with the choices
that you're making
so that's pretty much how it works and
obviously decision and player agency is
enormous in a game like this are you
going to have
like fully divergent paths like if you
make this choice
this bit like is locked to you or
is there a potentiality to just see
everything no it's impossible to see
everything which makes
uh life or quality assurance seem very
hard
and in this particular game it's much
much much more than what we did in our
previous
games uh so right from the get-go
when you're playing and you'll fee
you'll you encounter your first quest
huff
it's pretty big decisions to be made
right there that have consequences
across the entire game and it's very
cool to see uh
it's um i've i've been playing the
particular thing that i have in mind
and so many variations already and it's
every single time it's different and
it's it's really
neat to see the world throw data and
function of what i did so i really see
everything changed
that's something we didn't do in those
two so that's that's a big thing
and at the same time you have the same
thing with the characters well you saw
me
you saw that the pork known that the the
goblins have attached to windmill that
was turning around i could have left
them there
and then i will never see any of the
adventures that continue with him
but if i would have saved him and i
would have gone into the underdark i
will find him back there because he's
actually on a quest trying to save his
friends
he figured out that his friend is in
trouble and we call him internally we
call him the unfortunate gnome
and because it's just it's just one
after the other thing goes wrong for him
and then eventually he realized i'm no
hero
so he has a little arc like that anyway
i'm saying i'm telling you too much
already
but he he has a story that goes all the
way into baldur's gate depending
whether or not you're going to intersect
with his little own adventure that he's
trying to do
despite not being a hero and more kind
of looking
very forward into the future um you guys
have said
in the past that you don't think current
gen consoles would be able to run
a game as big as boulder's gate three so
do you have aims and aspirations and
obviously far reaching lofty goals for
like ps5
xbox series x or are you just thinking
we're gonna get it done first and think
about that
um i'm not 100 sure if it wouldn't be
able to run
on current gen consoles to be honest uh
it's just that
would be we haven't tried it let's put
it that way
so but i mean we managed to get those
two to run on a switch
which was actually something that we
thought was impossible also so
i guess that we're not going to say if
anything
dave the deliveries here
i'm leaving this in the interview by the
way
i would have imagined that you would
say what you're saying maybe next gen in
the future
uh well our focus right now is pc and
stadia
and that's a curveball question
so uh we're we're gonna first focus very
hard on getting those two to work and
then we'll see what
i mean like um it's it's a very very
very big game
and so we have a we have a lot of work
ahead of us right now
performance still needs to be heavily
optimized even on pc so
we'll let us first do that but the vibe
i'm getting it's
while you're handling an old school
franchise
what you seem to be aiming for with all
the new things you've added and all the
player agency
you're aiming for again trying to make
the next generation
of narrative rpgs that's the vibe i'm
getting
yeah i mean like our ambitions
internally for ourselves are very high
and there's a huge amount of dungeon and
dragon players in the office
so they want to get this right they want
to get the feeling that
this is a video game adaptation of
dungeon dragons that is something that
is that
does source material uh honor
and our feelings that we're on the right
track
so we in another interview
and i i said that we're we're learning
the language of the game
so it took us some time to actually
understand the language that it wanted
us to speak to it
but we figured it out now so development
right now is actually fairly smooth
because we all see
this is what we're making we understand
what we're making now so and but it
takes time to discover that
and so now we're adding a lot of content
uh cool content with very
it's very diverse also so you're not
going to see the same thing you know
with there's no
repetition of experience continuously
difference even every single fight well
the fights you saw today they were all
very different right so
and they started from simple setups but
evolved in these very complex situations
which is the type of gameplay that we
that we enjoy and i hope that the
players will like also
so there's a lot uh but uh at the core
we're trying to get you
the experience that you're playing an
adventure that it's your adventure
which uh reacted to the choices that you
make just like you do if you're
playing dungeons and dragons with a good
dungeon master
one of the most exciting things is that
you've shown me this game
a couple times now and you being someone
that's so intimately close to it every
time i watch you play it
even you go oh i didn't know that i
didn't know i could do that
so if you're saying that players are
going to
i mean i'm going to lose my mind with
all the things that i can experiment
with
well i'd say this is the beauty of
systemic design right so
what we do is we build systems and we
make sure that they interlock with each
other
but there's not by now there's so many
systems in there that it's a discovery
what can i do with all these systems
right and so
you see me try out a few things that
didn't work and then i was upset that
they didn't work because i expect them
to work because i trust the game systems
and the lead system designer was sitting
next to me and he's like saying oh damn
it why doesn't that work that should
have worked right so
but there's a there's a lot more subtle
systems that play also
and like i was very proud of myself i
mean we made it so that if you throw
a potion and the potion breaks the fluid
comes out which is logical what you
would expect
and i was very proud of myself that i
discovered that if i
snuck up in a goblin camp and stood like
10 meters
or what is that 30 feet or something
above it
and then i threw the portion potion into
a bucket of ale that the goblins were
drinking for them they would be poisoned
because they also actually when they
they they go and drink that's also
system and so they absorb
the properties of what's inside of there
and so that is very
it's just neat it's just very cool and i
mean like we made a script scene
sequence around pausing in the goblins
because it was a quest but the fact that
i could do it like this that was never
scripted that just happened
from the systems and so the same thing
you can do at many different locations i
mean like
i'm not 100 well i'll shut up about this
one
i had a because i have a similar thing
that that is very cool
uh but i'm not 100 sure if we're going
to keep it in so
more secrets well i as a huge rpg nerd
i'm
so very excited i know there's a lot of
people out there that's going to be
watching this that
are just as excited um so obviously the
next time you let me
get my greasy eyes on the game i'll be
sharing more with everyone at home but
until then sven thank you so much for
joining us and everyone out there
if you want to see more boulders gate 3
well subscribe to gamespot
i'll um i'll let you get your delivery
now mate
thanks dude
you